zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
lockern oder nicht lockern das ist die
große frage vor dem nächsten bund länder
treffen morgen viele viele menschen
wünschen sich lockerungen sehnlichst
herbei und gleichzeitig ist bei vielen
die angst und die sorge vor einer
dritten welle sehr sehr groß wie stehen
die linke und die afg als
oppositionsparteien zu dem was da morgen
entschieden werden könnte
darüber reden wir gleich und schauen uns
erst mal an was denn als
beschlussvorlage auf dem tisch liegt der
beschluss entwürfe die konferenz morgen
verlängert den schotter und erstmal bis
ende märz und wagt nur vorsichtige
öffnungen nach dem entwurf werden ab
nächster woche wieder treffen mit einem
weiteren haushalt möglich buchhandlungen
blumengeschäfte und gartenmärkte dürften
deutschlandweit wieder öffnen
ebenso flug und fahrschulen weitere
öffnungen aber sieht entwurf erst vor
wenn die inzidenz unter 35 liegt zum
ersten mal gibt es damit eine
perspektive für weitere öffnungen bei
guten werten strittig ist wie weit das
geht ja die entscheidungen fallen morgen
wir wollen heute schon über die konzepte
der opposition sprechen
wir wollen wissen was fordert die linke
darüber reden wir gleich mit der frisch
gewählten vorsitzenden susanne hennig
welse und wie ist das konzept der
größten oppositionspartei der afd
das ist die frage darüber spreche ich
mit jörg nolte dem bundessprecher der
afd
da ist er guten abend schön wird
vor ungefähr drei wochen vor der letzten
bund länder runde hat hier in dieser
sendung der fdp vorsitzende christian
lindner seinen sieben punkte plan seine
alternative vorgestellt wie ist denn das
konzept der afd
wir plädieren definitiv für schnelle
weitere lockerungen und zwar in kürzerer
frist und den größerem umfang als die
bundesregierung dass das liefert wenn
ich jetzt höre dass also eine weitere
verlängerung des lockt 128 3
vorgesehen ist dann halten wir das für
falsch das ziel muss sein so viel
normalität wie möglich und so viel
einschränkungen wie zwingend nötig und
die einschränkungen die wir haben die
entbehren leider doch sehr sehr stark
der verhältnismäßigkeit und der
angemessenheit wir haben es auch nicht
entsprechend evidenzbasiert wir haben
gar keine klare evidenz dafür dass die
schließung etwa von hotels gastronomie
und und von handel
die positiven wirkungen haben die davon
erhofft werden und solange wir das nicht
haben können wir hier nicht ein solches
strohfeuer machen wir haben vernichtende
wirkung auf die bildung der vernichtende
wirkung für die wirtschaft werben
vernichten die wirkungen übrigens auch
für andere bereiche des
gesundheitswesens und die
kollateralschäden übersteigen die nutzen
für unsere betreffe ganz deutlich
deswegen sagen wir den lock down zu
beenden nicht nicht vollständig also
sehen sie wenn heute abend borussia
mönchengladbach gegen borussia dortmund
spielt dann plädieren auch wir nicht
voll besetzt das stadion das sicherlich
nicht aber sie können sehen etwa bei den
spielern auf platz das mit den
vernünftigen hygiene konzept man doch
eine menge machen kann und das sollte
dann weiß gott nicht nur für bundesliga
profis gelten sondern für die menschen
im land ganz allgemein auch und zum
beispiel auch für freizeitsportler die
fußball spielen wenn es in der
bundesliga geht dann kann es mit verlaub
auch für unsere kinder gehen in den
fußballverein und sonstigen sportverein
des landes oder in den schulen und
kindertagesstätten zum beispiel die
zahlen lagen die die zahlen lage die sie
ansprechen ist ja nicht ganz so dass es
keine zahlen gebe wir haben zum einen
steigen die infektions werte
wir haben eine inzidenz von ungefähr 65
und wir haben vor allem eine auf dem
vormarsch sich befindliche mutation die
forderungen die sie gerade gestellt
haben oder die vorschläge die sie
gemacht haben sind ja durchaus
vielfältig genauso übrigens wie die
haltung innerhalb der afg im verlauf der
pandemie und wie breit die bandbreite da
ist das zeigt uns david gepackt ein jahr
coruña kampf der afg mit sich selbst
zwischen regierungskritik und
verschwörungs mythen während im frühjahr
die einen den shutdown wollen glauben
andere corona wurde geplant und bill
gates plane zwangsimpfungen
die einen fordern masten andere
verteufeln sie es muss ein augenmerk zum
beispiel auf das konsequente tragen von
mund- und nasenschutz massen gelegt
werden
ich sage auch nicht maske dazu das ist
ein maulkorb das ist eine unterdrückung
symbol im sommer schon behauptet nfd
landeschef corona ist professionell
wieder auf die abgeordnete suchen
demonstrativ den schulterschluss auf
sogenannten querdenker demos geraten zum
teil mit der polizei aneinander und
verharmlosen die judenverfolgung der
ns-zeit die tendenz stellen dass man
leute aus ganz ganze bevölkerungsgruppen
haus sind das ist heute realität und das
ist vergleichbar mit wie man mit juden
umgegangen ist
in den 30er jahren fraktionschef gauland
spricht im herbst wiederholt von einer
cola diktatur auf wiederum wir leben in
keiner diktatur sonst könnten wir diesen
parteitag heute wohl auch kaum so
abhalten widerspricht parteichef wollten
wer anderes behaupte stelle die
systemfrage mahnungen die zumindest in
der ostafrikaner winter verheißt
jedenfalls werde auch künftig die korona
diktator als cora diktator bezeichnen
ich rufe euch hiermit auf wilde
verschwörungstheorien zwischen bruder
verschwörung und inhaltlicher
regierungskritik inmitten der
jahrhundert pandemie versinkt die afg im
richtungsstreit haben wollten sie sind
bundessprecher dieser partei ist das
seriöse politik wir haben das wurde in
dem bericht jetzt gezeigt sehr
unterschiedliche positionen in der
partei
das ist aber nicht eine sache die
exklusiv bei der afg so ist also david
cocordan gleich sitzungen mit dem
holocaust bezüge zur judenverfolgung in
welcher anderen partei sehen sie das
sie müssen mich ausreden lassen erklärt
david gebhard hat am sonntag der
reportage gemacht in berlin direkt da
sagte herr laschet auf die
unterschiedlichen positionen in der
union bezogen dass es sehr
unterschiedliche positionen in der union
gibt noch ist der kasten ist das eine
position den holocaust zu leugnen
ich bitte sie das tut in meiner partei
kein mensch und vergleichen mit der ns
zeit sind völlig unangemessen ich habe
das wieder und wieder gesagt sieht
nehmen natürlich auch die wenigen
einzelnen heraus die so etwas machen
haben da ist zu sehr leid dass ich stehe
auch das noch mal unterbrechen aber ein
ganz kurzer blick und ich habe wirklich
nicht lange gesucht in ihren eigenen
facebook-account da habe ich unter
anderem gefunden ein post von jochen
calvin so wie es gerade in deutschland
ist genau so begann es auch schon 1934
abgesehen davon dass es 1933 war das ist
ihr facebook-account was sagen sie dazu
dazu sage ich ihnen dass ich jeden tag
tausende von kommentaren auf meiner
facebook seite habe dass mitarbeiter die
durchforsten das sowas aber durchaus
eine gewisse zeit stehen bleiben kann
weil man nicht alles sofort findet und
mit verlaub ich verantworte nicht die
tausende von kommentaren da muss ich
meine facebook-seite abstellen zeigen
sie mir einen einzigen kommentar von mir
selbst auf meiner facebook seite und ich
habe sehr viel zucker oder publiziert
was auch nur ansatzweise anfechtbar ist
das werden sie nicht finden aber wir
haben habe gerade gesehen da eines users
okay aber wir haben gerade sehr viele
auch prominente köpfe aus ihrer partei
gesehen die ähnliches machen im moment
es sind einige ganz wenige die das
schräge vergleiche angestellt haben die
werden jetzt in dieser reportage bemüht
nun bleiben wir doch mal einfach bei den
positionen dessen was die
bundesregierung sich aktuell ein
versagen erlaubt und dann sind wir im
tagesaktuellen bereich und schauen mal
was die da machen mit der inzidenz 35
mit den mit dem völligen versagen sie
erst das masken versagen wenn das imker
sagen jetzt hat das schnell test
versagen in einem ford lassen sie uns
doch darüber sprechen dass die aufgabe
einer oppositionspartei hier den finger
in die wunde zu legen das tun wir und
das ist auch richtig so
es gibt eine insa umfrage im auftrag der
jungen freiheit
danach würden aktuell von 33,5 prozent
der unionswähler 4 prozent mehr die afg
wählen wenn die partei corona nicht
verharmlosen würde die würden ihnen doch
eigentlich ganz gut tun bei den
derzeitigen umfragewerten wie wollen sie
die dann erreichen wenn zum beispiel ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender
immer noch von einer corona diktatur
spricht oder einer ihrer fraktion im
november oder dezember getan
eine verharmlosung von corona haben wir
nicht eine sehr klare konsistente corona
position übrigens der bundestagsfraktion
die ich bei der stelle durchaus mal oder
der stelle durchaus mal beruhigen kann
da werden auch ganz konkrete vorschläge
gemacht die werden aber mehr ideal nicht
so aufführen als wenn da mal
irgendjemand mit einem einzel begriffe
über die stränge schlägt wir haben sehr
saubere position ich bin grad letzte
woche essen berlin von der
biologielehrer auf offener straße
angesprochen worden
die sagte danke dass sie diese position
vertreten sie sind hier die einzigen und
die schilderten ihre erfahrungen zum
beispiel homeschooling ihrer kinder und
auch ihre erfahrungen als lehrer
das erlebe ich selber zu hause auch ich
habe vier kinder im homeschooling und
ich kann ihnen sagen was das heißt und
ich kann ihnen das nicht sagen wir
irgendwo höre sondern weil ich selbst
erlebe das ist wirklich schwer für die
kinder und es ist auch unglaublich
schwer für das lehrpersonal den den
stoff dann noch rüber zu bringen
und wenn sie das über monate machen dann
haben sie psychosoziale wirkungen die
sind enorm und diese kollateralschäden
die sind das was mich wirklich umtreibt
und das ist auch dass unsere partei
umtreibt so dass wir sagen
neben dem wirtschaftlichen desaster
machen wir ein psychosoziales desaster
in der bevölkerung
wir haben eine pandemie kein mensch der
bei verstand ist stellt das in abrede
aber die menschen gehen daran setzen
dass ich nicht alles sehr vernünftig
damit um das haben wir gerade gesehen
dass er gesagt hat corona ist im sommer
vorbei ja da wissen sie ja dazu befragen
da hat er ganz gewaltig geirrt das kommt
bei einer hecke schon mal vor dass kommt
aber mit verlaub bei herrn sparen auch
was hat herr spahn alles über masken
gesagt er hat gesagt kein mensch braucht
diese masken nicht
zwei monate später brauchte auf einmal
jeder diese masken also übrigens so
richtig hatte aber sie sehen daran dass
es da viele irrtümer gab hier haben sie
jetzt ein irrtum von herrn ecke gebracht
den würde wahrscheinlich auch erhöhte
heute frank und frei als er schon
bezeichnen denn etwas anderes als das
kommt dafür nicht in frage
nun ist es natürlich ein unterschied ob
man sachen hinterfragt weil sich der
wissenschaftliche fortschritt weiter
bewegt und man erkenntnisse hat die man
noch nicht hatte oder ob man
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse leugnet
und trotzdem auf seiner meinung beharrt
ich würde ganz gerne mal zum thema
impfen kommen
und auch dazu haben wir zusammengefasst
welche positionen in ihrer partei da
vertreten werden die afg hat immer
gesagt wir müssen zu allererst die
hochrisikogruppen schützen auch die
gesundheitsämter hätten sich darum
kümmern müssen und nicht um verfolgung
von infektionsketten diese längst
verloren haben und nicht mehr nach
verfolgen können die 80 jährigen firmen
80er 90-jährigen ob das ob der impfstoff
möglicherweise spätfolgen hat
interessiert die nicht mehr dem wollen
jetzt geimpft werden weil sie jetzt die
angst haben zu recht kritisch ist auch
dieser gesetzesentwurf in dem vor allem
ältere patienten oder hochrisiko
patienten zuerst geimpft werden sollen
das halten wir ehrlich gesagt für
komplett falsch und nicht zu für
zielführend da in dieser gruppe auch mit
den höchsten nebenwirkungen des hoch
experimentellen mrm schiff zu rechnen
ist
es wird nachgedacht wird die störung tom
privatwohnung des inhaftierung und es
geht um 20 punkte und verändernden rna
allen stoff alle schafe in verruf sind
gefallen
liebe freunde ist aber nach wie vor es
gibt keine wissenschaftliche evidenz für
eine typische notlage nationaler
bedeutung
es tut mir leid dass wir ihnen immer
mitführen hätte kommen müssen aber ist
landesvorsitzender in thüringen wir
müssen feststellen dass hier nicht nur
cola vorhaben los und lügen über den
impfstoff verbreitet er übrigens auch
beim kollegen im bundestag diskreditiert
wurde die afg will die alten zuerst
impfen sie will die alten nicht zuerst
impfen
wie stehen sie denn jetzt zum thema
impfen ich kann ihnen meine einstellung
dazu sagen auch die einstellung der
mehrheit der partei
ich kann aber natürlich nicht rede und
antwort schäfer positionen die die arche
irgendwo vertritt da müssen sie schon
mit der merkel selber reden dass das
nicht meine aufgabe das zu tun
wir teilen grundsätzlich die auffassung
dass die impfungen eine sinnvolle und
wichtige geschichte ist die das kann
kein mensch bestreiten natürlich auch
mit risiken einher geht jemand abwägen
muss um die pandemie die es sehr wohl
gibt
zu überwinden das ist überhaupt keine
frage und dann muss man eben schauen
welcher strategie verimpft man richtig
wir prangern aber sehr sehr stark an das
impf desaster dass wir haben ich meine
schauen sie sich doch mal an wie die
impfquote in israel ist wie sie übrigens
in großbritannien es ich spreche zu
ihnen aus brüssel
die briten sind gegangen sie sind der
staat in europa der die höchste
impfquote hat und das obwohl sich der eu
nicht mehr angehören angehören
währenddessen hat frau von der leyen mit
der kommission die ein einziges desaster
angerichtet und mit verlaub nicht nur
ich stelle fest dass durch die spätere
neben von menschenleben gefährdet werden
menschen eventuell zu tode kommen
das hat es letzte woche frau
maischberger zu herrn schäuble gesagt in
der sendung und sie hatte recht
nochmal zum thema impfung an sich zum
thema impfstoff an sich welche risiken
sind ihnen denn bekannt außer einer
vorübergehenden grippeähnlichen
erscheinungen fieber zum beispiel oder
schmerzen im arm welche risiken sind
ihnen bekannt
schauen sie das sind ja sachen sind wir
doch ehrlich und und machen uns da
keinen vor und setzen das auch nicht
politisch ein sondern sagen einfach
natürlich sind vereinzelt menschen nach
impfung verstorben
jetzt muss man das ist sozusagen seinen
die nach der impfung gestorben sind und
es gibt in keinem einzigen fall einen
zusammenhang zur impfung sagt das
paul-ehrlich-institut wissen sie das
jetzt gesichert übrigens die zahl 119
habe ich nicht aber die zahl von über
200 aber dass jetzt die frage in welchem
bereich das ist
ich will ja ich bin der letzte verstehen
sie mich bitte richtig und
interpretieren sie mich nicht falsch ich
bin der letzte der in panik schritt
überhaupt nicht ich bin für die impfung
um das deutlich zu sagen aber es gibt
natürlich auch im friesischen und wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel an meine kinder
denken die minderjährig sind dann ist
für die das corona risiko so gering dass
ich die nicht impfen lassen würde mich
selbst studiert er auch gerade gar
niemand über kinder aber das
interessiert nicht würden sie sich
selbst impfen lassen ich werde mich wenn
ich dran bin impfen lassen ich habe das
nach reiflicher überlegung für mich so
entschlossen
ich warte das geduldig ab und wenn ich
dran wenn dann werde ich mich impfen
lassen aber lassen sie mich eines sagen
was mir extrem wichtig ist es ist eines
jeden menschen eigene und freie
entscheidung und es kann nicht sein dass
wir einen impfzwang durch die hintertür
bekommen in dem menschen diskriminiert
werden die eine andere entscheidung für
sich treffen als ich das
der ich mich impfen lassen will das
müssen die menschen selber wissen und
diese freiheit darf man ihnen nicht
nehmen und man darf sie auch nicht dafür
diskriminieren das nicht es geht hier um
die einschränkung von grundrechten die
wir haben und es sind nicht rechte die
der staat großzügiger weise gewährt
sondern das sind rechte die die menschen
haben und es muss jede einschränkung von
grundrechten einzelnen separat sehr
sorgfältig begründet werden denn das ein
sehr ernster zusammenhang und wir haben
hier sicherlich unverhältnismäßige
einschränkung
nun funktioniert das nur wenn sich die
menschen freiwillig impfen lassen dass
sie davon überzeugt sind dass sie sich
impfen lassen
warum stellen sie sich denn eigentlich
nicht hin und sagen leute nehmt den
verzeihen sie die wortwahl aber das hier
ist eine junge sendung geilen scheiß aus
deutschland in mainz entwickelt mit
deutscher expertise von einem deutschen
institute nach einem mediziner benannt
der den nobelpreis bekommen hat nehmt
einfach dieses zeug und lasst euch
impfen das fähig aber aus der afg nicht
ich sehe den gesundheitspolitischen
sprecher im bundestag der sagt die
impfung ist okay aber ich nehme sie
selbst nicht ich setze auf mein
immunsystem
es ist doch ihre aufgabe als
parteivorsitzender dann eine klare linie
reinzubringen und warum nicht die lasst
euch einfach alle impfen damit diese
pandemie zu ende geht das noch mal weil
wir eine freiheitliche partei sind und
zur freiheitlichen partei gehört
meinungspluralismus es ist zulässig
diese andere position dazu zu haben und
ich kann hier nur wiederholen jeder
mensch muss das für sich selbst
entscheiden
ich persönlich ich werde auch in meinem
privaten umfeld dafür aber auch viele
mediziner in meinem umfeld die dass die
das gleichermaßen tun bin durchaus dafür
aber ist als partei- position von oben
zu erklären bei der unterschiedlichkeit
der der position die es da gibt und auch
mit verlaub der noch nicht sauberen
wissenschaftlichen evidenz die wir haben
dazu ist es einfach noch zu früh dann zu
sagen nur so kann das gehen quasi
autoritär das würde ich für falsch
halten wenn das steht einer
freiheitlichen partei mit verlaub auch
nicht gut an
das stimmt die wissenschaftliche
expertise des paul-ehrlich-instituts mit
seiner mehr als 100 jahre alten
geschichte anzuzweifeln steht ihnen
natürlich frei
herr ganz herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch danke für das interview
nach brüssel und danke für die
erläuterungen und ausführungen schönen
abend dankeschön und damit begrüße ich
susanne hennig will so noch
fraktionschefin der linken in thüringen
und seit dem wochenende eine der beiden
frisch gewählten vorsitzenden der linken
hände ich will so lassen sie uns ganz
kurz noch einmal gemeinsam darauf
blicken was denn möglicherweise morgen
geplant ist damit wir dann hören können
was ihre stellungnahme dazu ist also auf
dem tisch liegt eine beschlussvorlage
nach der der schotter und bis zum 28
märz verlängert werden würde
öffnungen würden wenn dann nur
vorsichtig vorgesehen seien ab nächster
woche wieder treffen mit einem weiteren
haushalt das wäre möglich buchhandlungen
blumengeschäfte und gartenmärkte dürften
deutschlandweit wieder öffnen hier sehen
wir es noch mal genau private treffen
buchhandlungen blumengeschäfte ebenso
die flug und fahrschulen dürften wieder
öffnen
weitere öffnungen aber sieht der entwurf
erst vor wenn die inzidenz unter 35
liegt
ich will so wenn sie das sehen ist das
in ihrem sinne oder was wäre das konzept
der linken wenn sie morgen entscheiden
dürften es wohl schon genannt wenn ich
morgen entscheiden dürfte dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich so entscheidend sind noch
von ich halte lockerungs debatte
falschen rebecca mir gehen strafft auch
eine dritte welle zu die mutation das
auch in deutschland angekommen und ich
für meinen teil finde es am allerbesten
und eine gründungswelle mit dem bund
zusammen einstufen können vereinbaren
würden
der mit der offenbar jetzt nicht vor
aber der stufenplan der bedeutet wenn
man mit welchen ins ländchen
möglicherweise öffnen kann
beziehungsweise ben x ab wann man wieder
schließt muss das alles scheint ziemlich
willkürlich zu sein auch gartenmärkte
buch lesen das finde ich alles okay aber
es ist natürlich weg wenn ich
rausgesucht wahrscheinlich weil die
arbeit und dann höchst nur war ich
glaube dass ein enormes debatte und
keinen schritt weiter bringt im moment
der frage von luca schmidt die uns hier
bei youtube erreicht sind sie dafür den
lock down zu beenden würden sie so
pauschal mit nein beantworten ich wäre
dafür den doktor zu beenden wenn wir aus
meiner sicht vier punkte erfüllen das
eine ist natürlich die im kapazität dort
nicht zu erhöhen damit wir wesentlich
mehr menschen schützen können das würde
zweitens bedeuten dass wir jetzt sparen
per verordnung freies impfen zu lassen
der klassiker wäre das könnte ich alle
vorstellen bei ikea linken oder in
anderen einrichtungen der dritte punkt
ist das gewährleistet sein muss dass
jeder und jede sich selbst schützen kann
dass es auch bezahlbar bleibt deswegen
am besten kostenfrei durch den bund
finanziert machten zu haben sich test
wird ständig in der apotheke zu holen
und der dritte punkt ist die
internationale dimension die man jetzt
im alltag nicht besonders begleiten
aber wenn wir es nicht schaffen group
einzuimpfen und die patienten vorher
freizugeben damit das möglich ist werden
wir die pandemie so schnell nicht
besiegen können
nun haben wir wenn wir auf die linke
gucken festgestellt dass es auch in
ihrer partei unterschiedliche haltungen
zu den zu den maßnahmen gibt wir haben
gesehen dass ihr vorgänger duo riexinger
und kipping zum beispiel oft gesagt hat
die beschlüsse gehen uns nicht weit
genug da hätte man sich an einer oder
anstellen verschärfungen gewünscht dann
gab es dietmar bahn stehe er die
eröffnungs strategie verfolgt hat und
sie stehen jetzt vor der herausforderung
sie stehen neu an der parteispitze und
haben aber quasi noch die
regierungsverantwortung in thüringen im
rücken oder im gepäck susanne freitag
hat uns das zusammengefasst vorerst
digital gewählt im super war ja seit
samstag ist die thüringerin susanne
hennig welt so eine der beiden linken
chefinnen und im wahlkampfmodus in
sachen corona und impfungen deutliche
worte für den politischen gegner leeres
arango ist natürlich aus meiner sicht
das impfen der bevölkerung und das
wieder ein massives im versagen und
staatsversagen auf seiten der cdu neben
dem fall sein ist ja genähte durch die
cdu im und spanien schon merkel von der
neuen und kritik an den verantwortlichen
in bund und eu
doch in thüringen regiert die
linkspartei selbst und der freistaat hat
seit wochen die höchste instanz aller
bundesländer
der einzige linke ministerpräsident bodo
ramelow hat eingestanden dass seine
strategie der lockerungen im herbst
falsch war
susanne hennig welt so plädiert für
einen mittelweg aus der krise vorsicht
mit lockerungen dafür aber mehr hilfen
für wirtschaft und familien und sie
fordert im solidarität mit ärmeren
ländern zur bevor wir weiter machen der
aufmerksame zuschauer oder die
zuschauerin hat es gemerkt wenn die
kolleginnen wie wochentage heißen dann
kommt die moderatorin durcheinander das
war der beitrag von daniela sonntag und
nicht der von susanne freitag das tut
mir leid liebe daniela aber jetzt zum
punkt freuen ich will so sie sprechen
von im solidarität mit ärger und ländern
das ist ja eine schöne idee aber wir
haben ja selber im moment nicht genug
impfstoff
na ja das bin ich dem stoffen ist jetzt
tatsächlich an druck nehmen
sie haben den thüringen in ihrem beitrag
angesprochen unsere infrastruktur steht
wir könnten viel mehr in einen umschlag
wenn es möglich wäre tatsächlich im
schlaf zu finden und das ist natürlich
eine kette die das staatsversagen an der
spitze der bundesrepublik jetzt in die
männer weiter trägt und wäre damit zu
tun haben dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger über volle rund neun cent dass
sie keine termine bekommen dass die
weggeschickt mir dass sie weit fahren
müssen eben einfach deshalb weil er kein
impfstoff hand den wir verwenden können
und dennoch steht es den westlichen
industrie sehr zugute sich nicht nur
selbst sondern global zu impfen weil wir
sonst mit fini den finder mutation
rechnen müssen
mit
eine nicht ausrottung der krankheit und
das geht natürlich in dem man patente
zum beispiel freigibt und damit auch
produktion in anderen teilen dieser erde
erlaubt und darum geht es das ist nennt
man solidarität und die in diesem fall
auch noch ein regler egoismus ist fragt
niels b über youtube was halten sie von
einer zwei klassen gesellschaft
eingeteilt in geimpfte und nicht
geimpfte also ich halte davon überhaupt
nichts ersten zerstörtes und einen
solidarischen gedanken gemeinsam diese
krise zu meistern zweitens sondern ein
nicht jede und jeder wann immer er sie
es möchten sich impfen lassen kann
macht das überhaupt gar keinen sinn
darüber zu reden dass die ängste
praktisch wäre entweder ihrer
freiheitsrechte wie ihnen ja de facto
auch zu stehen
in aller form wieder aufnehmen können
noch dazu wo er dann nicht wissen ob das
hat sich noch ansteckend sind oder nicht
und der punkt ist solange wir nicht
garantieren können dass jede natürlich
schützen kann über eine impfung
er sollte der stadt in keinem fall
eingreifen allerdings was der staat
nicht verhindern kann wird private für
sich entscheidet zum beispiel von
gesellschaft und busgesellschaften was
auch immer das nur ängste bei den
mietpreisen können das kann der staat
wenig beeinflussen aber ich werde dafür
tatsächlich diesen gute steht nicht zu
machen
hier gibt es eine frage von maddie neu
auch über youtube ich würde vorher nicht
weil so gerne fragen was sie von zero
cobit hält sie hört sich erst mal gut an
und man muss zur kenntnis nehmen das ist
ja eine sehr weitreichende idee ist die
versucht also auch google auf einem
anderen weg nämlich einen kompletten
shutdown auszurotten bzw
nicht mehr anstecken kann macht dabei zu
wenig angesteckt sind aber gleichzeitig
bedeutet das eigentlich eigentlich im
und grundrechte der viel viel härter
noch mal als mieter ordnung noch dort in
deutschland wirken
und deswegen werde ich
sehr vorsichtig mit dieser idee zumal
sich jetzt irgendwann auch aus meiner
sicht gesellschaftlichen überhaupt nicht
ich würde gerne ein bisschen drauf
eingehende was auch die wortwahl und die
strategie ihrer partei in der pandemie
war und zitiere unter anderem dietmar
bartsch dem bundestag von einer papst
attitüde der unfehlbarkeit der kanzlerin
gesprochen hat nun sind sie nicht
dietmar bartsch aber haben sie da nicht
auch eine verantwortung als partei wie
dieser diskurs geführt wird
dann sind definitiv recht dass wir auch
noch andere waren wie dieser diskurs
geführt wird nicht direkt denn an der
deutlichkeit dass die kanzlerin
natürlich eine lange zeit den eindruck
gemacht hat den richtigen weg zu kennen
bodo ramelow ist in anderen weg gegangen
konnte im november natur zu zeigen zu
sein ich habe mich geirrt wir hätten
anders handeln müssen wenn es das meint
kann ich das unredlich verstehen
ok ok jemand anderes von dem ich nicht
genau weiß ob sie es verstehen über den
würde ich auch gerne sprechen wie gehen
sie denn damit um dass eine der
prominentesten vertreterinnen ihrer
partei nämlich sahra wagenknecht auf
youtube die wutbürger abholt wir haben
uns mal eine passage rausgesucht bei der
sie quasi die demokratischen grundlagen
der entscheidungen in frage stellt er
finde die art wie inzwischen es sich
eingeschliffen hat dass man eben von
oben herab entschieden wird elementare
grundrechte einzuschränken oder zu
gewähren auch gewerbe anhalt ist ein
grundrecht das hat wirklich so den
gestus von gnaden akten dem einen wird
nahe gewährt im anderen nicht was ist
das für ein verständnis von
rechtsstaatlichkeit
auch das ist ein teil ihrer partei frau
hennig will so wie kommentieren sie das
meine perspektive ist die dass
gesundheitsschutz den höchsten die
höchste aufmerksamkeit braucht in dieser
zeit und das wäre freiheitsrechte
deswegen auch um der exekutive und in
den zuständigen konsumenten jetzt
bestätigt konsument auch an den
verordnung beteiligt und führt auch die
debatte mit den jeweiligen regierungen
deswegen weiß ich natürlich sehr genau
das werk grundrechte wie freiheit der
bewegung und einschränken
aber aus meiner sicht ist es dringend
notwendig und tatsächlich den
gesundheitsschutz für alle zu
gewährleisten und solidarisch dafür zu
sorgen dass eben nicht was einen
menschen sterben nicht sterben müssen
wenn wir miteinander umgehen ist eine
das inhaltliche das andere ja die
wortwahl das ist ja genau das was
populisten gerne machen das was frau
magen wagenknecht tut sie diskreditiert
politische entscheidungsfindungen und
sie legt den verdacht nahe dass in
hinterzimmern irgendwas ausgekungelt
wird was eben in einer demokratie nichts
zu suchen hat dem muss man doch begegnen
als parteiführung das gesagt hat war ich
noch gar nicht parteiführung obst da sie
diese gut wenn wir nicht mögen bedeutet
das finde ich darauf hin wie ich dazu
stehen dann bin ich gespannt auf ihr
statement zur nächsten wochen heißt sie
glaube ich von sahra wagenknecht eine
frage habe ich noch zur zur
sonntagsfrage laut aktuellen
politbarometer liegt die linke da
derzeit bei sieben prozent
bei der letzten bundestagswahl waren es
9,2 woran liegt das dass die linken
nicht profitieren kann im moment ist die
zweite exekutive spricht der regierung
und die regierung gestiegen im fokus und
entscheiden und gestalten in diesem
moment mit verordnungen und gesetzen die
in einer schnelligkeit durch die
parlamente gehen ist natürlich also ein
thüringen wenn man eine ganz andere
situation was die märkte angeht aber
bundesweit als bundes partei sind wir
natürlich der weniger im fokus
obwohl linke an
mit dieser zeit durchaus sehr gefragt
sind deswegen glaube ich wenn wir
tatsächlich jetzt die dritte wenn er
überwunden haben und möglicherweise mit
einer großen des impfens in den sommer
kommen dass die politischen verhältnisse
sich andere völlig neu gestalten und
auch die linke eine größere bedeutung
hat und ein weiterer punkt ist natürlich
dass die konsequente unserer politischen
vorschläge für den linke auch so weit
gehen muss das mir darum kämpft mit
einem progressiven bündnis unseren part
zu finden
zur nächsten bundestagswahl option auf
regierungsbeteiligung
ich würde gern noch mal zum impfen
fragen weil sie die offensive des
impfens angesprochen haben wie ist das
in thüringen mecklenburg-vorpommern aus
mecklenburg vorpommern haben wir heute
gehört dass der astra zeneca impfstoff
für die im priorität 2 freigegeben
werden soll auch hier in rheinland pfalz
zum beispiel werden jetzt lehrerinnen
und lehrer hat ihren erzieherinnen und
erzieher geimpft wie ist das in
thüringen sehen sie dass dort auch vor
und sollte aus ihrer sicht an der ems
priorisierung was geändert werden also
in thüringen sind sehr ähnlich auch
pädagogisches personal geimpft werden
und da sind auch die meisten termine
schon ausgebucht und grundsätzlich bin
ich dafür dass die nächste ins gruppe
tatsächlich geholfen und wird damit der
astra teenager impfstoff hat sich auch
für internet und nicht so auch jetzt
habe ich gerade gerade denn den den
anschluss verpasst weil mir jemand
parallel was aufs ohr gesagt hat aber
wir sind gut in der zeit das war die
information die ich gerade bekommen habe
noch eine frage hätte ich zum thema
datenschutz denn es geht auch darum dass
die econa waren app vieles kann vieles
aber auch nicht kann und es gibt ja
durchaus positionen zu sagen wir haben
so viele einschränkungen bei den
grundrechten erlebt was freiheitsrechte
angeht oder bewegungsfreiheit oder was
auch immer man müsste beim datenschutz
viel mehr justieren und der app vielmehr
ermöglichen
dann könnte man auch bei anderen sachen
wieder lockerer lassen was ist ihre
position dazu
ja ich glaube wenn man in diesem punkt
den datenschutz noch und wird niemand
mehr diese planen das heißt man hat das
war vielleicht mehr möglichkeit mit
dieser app ehre wenn sie keiner mehr
nicht mach das auch gar keinen sinn
britischen gentleman geht das heißt sie
würden aber auch instrumente aus der
hand geben wie das einige staaten machen
indem man zum beispiel die gps daten
trägt oder so es geht ja nicht nur darum
dass man diese app öffnet sondern dass
man möglicherweise auch handydaten zur
nachverfolgung ganz anders nutzt relativ
attraktiv aber das ist jetzt tatsächlich
und oder andersrum
ich wäre schwer dagegen der app
tatsächlich mehr möglichkeiten uns auch
wenn es bedeutet dass man zum beispiel
für kultur und gastronomie im moment
wenig perspektiven hat einfach weil die
zahlen noch zu hoch sind und die
nachverfolgung an ihre grenzen kommen
sieht man ja fast nichts anderes als in
ihm raus ob ein handy das kann man alles
machen aber das bedeutet natürlich den
namen wie nicht gewährleistet wird dass
diese daten niemals weitergegeben werden
einen prägnanten und und im sinne von
der überwachung von menschen kann man
das nicht durchziehen und ich sehe nicht
dass es diese gewährleisten gibt
gleichzeitig kann man aber auch
schwerlich akzeptieren dass es diese app
gibt die quasi überhaupt nicht
funktioniert oder nur von einem
bruchteil der bevölkerung genutzt wird
erledigen auch recht aber wenn ja wenn
mehr leute in der regierung diese app
überhaupt nutzen würde
eine schale in richtung der perspektive
auf nächste woche habe ich noch aus soll
ab nächster woche selbsttests in den
discountern geben oder in
drogeriemärkten für alle die sich das
selber leisten können und wollen der
einkaufspreis liegt ungefähr bei vier
euro das heißt die tests werden dann
würde ich jetzt mal mutmaßen ungefähr
bei zehn euro liegen wird dass am ende
eine soziale frage wer an welchen dingen
teilhaben kann und wer nicht
eine frage wer in welchen dingen
teilnehmen kann oder nicht das ganze
stichwort zwei masken natürlich wenn man
tests bezahlen muss wird man keine tests
machen und wenn man am öffentlichen
leben teilhaben will dann ist man
einfach dabei uns zu machen obwohl
möglicherweise symptome hat deswegen ist
meine partei und werde ich sehr dafür
dass auch tests kostenfrei oder für ein
sehr geringes geld abgegeben werden in
apotheken
weil sonst auch die christ strategie
damit knüpft das ja überhaupt nicht
aufgeht die frage der finanzierung
können wir dann vielleicht noch mal
diskutieren wenn wir nochmal zeit haben
für einen stream zum thema corona und
den wird ganz bestimmt geben
vielen dank susanne hennig will so für
diese einschätzungen danke für das
interview und an dieser stelle möchte
ich gerne noch eine frage beantworten
die uns hier im chat erreicht hat
nämlich die frage warum wir die afg und
die linke auf eine stufe stellen
das tun wir nicht wir haben einfach die
oppositionsparteien gefragt heute in
dieser sendung diese beiden wie wir
zuvor schon die fdp befragt haben und es
wäre ja vielleicht auch eine gute idee
vor der nächsten bund länder sitzung die
es auch ganz bestimmt wieder geben wird
auch mit den grünen zu sprechen also auf
jeden fall reden wir hier natürlich auch
mit der opposition aus guten gründen und
das haben wir heute mit diesen beiden
parteien getan
vor der sitzung morgen möchte ich ihnen
außerdem gerne noch das format ins halb
politics ans herz legen dass mein
kollege florian neuhann in dieser woche
gespielt nämlich mit der frage was ist
das eigentlich für ein gremium das sich
da trifft ein sehr interessanter blick
hinter die kulissen auf unserer seite
und auch über youtube zu finden
und ansonsten wünsche ich ihnen morgen
gute unterhaltung beim stream zum thema
bund-länder-treffen nächste runde und
wir sind sehr gespannt welche
entscheidungen morgen getroffen werden
bleiben sie uns gewogen das denn
[Musik]